- So I'm sure today and
in the next few days,
you'll learn about new capabilities,
which is allow you to build
and scale applications in AWS.
But remember, that's the
first part of your job.
The second part of the job
is to secure this application
and protect these applications.
So today, we're going to talk about
how to build secure
perimeter protection on AWS.
I'm Shovan Das and I'm a Product Manager
in AWS networking team.
I lead the area of Zero
Trust Networking and WAN.
And with me, I have Megha Kande.
She leads the CloudFront team
and she will talk about edge security.
And with me, I also have Sohaib Tahir,
who is a Principal Solution Architect.
And he will give a cool demo
of how to build end-to-end
perimeter protection
using GenAI and Kiro CLIs.
So I'm pretty excited about that demo.
So today, we'll talk
broadly what security means
for an application on AWS,
what's the perimeter protection needs.
Then we'll go into perimeter
protection at the edge.
Then we'll talk about traffic
inspection within the network.
And then finally, we'll talk
about giving end users access
to those application and
resources hosted on AWS.
And then we'll wrap up with
a cool demo like I talked.
So most of our customers, they
have two kinds of application
or resources hosted on AWS.
The first is public application.
So think of it, your retail website.
Any user can access
that, your API gateway.
Anybody can use those API gateway
and connect to your applications.
And you need to protect those.
But also you have private applications.
For example, you have your
HR system running in AWS,
your financial dashboard running in AWS.
Your employees, your workforce,
your contractor access those.
These are private applications.
Not only that, you have all
these applications run on EC2,
containers, RDS instances.
Your end engineers, developers, analysts,
they access those instances.
They are doing SSH for their daily jobs.
So at the end of the
day, you need to protect
the applications, the data
in those applications,
and provide a robust perimeter protection.
And when I think of building a perimeter,
I think of four traffic directions.
First is the internet ingress.
That's where your users
connect via the internet,
but malicious actor, DDoS,
bad actors can sneak in.
So you need to protect that angle.
Then your applications are also
connecting to the internet,
like GitHub downloading content,
or they're uploading some
code patching, those things.
So you need to ensure they are going
and accessing the authorized website.
They are putting in the
data that is compliant
based on organizational needs.
And the third direction
is your applications
are also talking to other applications.
So you need to ensure that
only the right applications
are talking to the right application.
That's to prevent lateral movement.
Let's say somebody sneaks
into one of your applications,
and then from that application they jump
into some other application, right?
And the final direction is
your employees, your workforce.
They're also accessing
to get their jobs done.
And you want to ensure
that only the right users,
the users with the right privilege,
are accessing the application
on the nearby basis.
Once you have done those,
you have built a perimeter protection.
So what we'll do today in this session,
we'll talk about a fictitious
customer SecureShop.
And they have two kinds of applications.
One is the retail website, secureshop.com.
And then they have a private
application, financecode.com.
These applications are hosted in AWS.
So they are hosted in VPC.
Their application is spread
across multiple VPCs.
So they are connected via TGW.
And our customer, secureshop.com,
to provide better performance,
content acceleration,
and caching, is also using CloudFront
for that public-facing websites.
And they also have applications
and employee in on-prem.
Those employees and
applications are also accessing
to the transit gateway to the VPCs.
So first, they will do
the perimeter protection
against DDoS and other attacks
from the internet ingress.
Then they will protect
all the traffic directions
coming from internet to their application.
Then they will protect the
east-west traffic between VPCs.
And finally, they will protect the traffic
and inspect the traffic
coming from on-prem
and give end users the access.
And once they complete all these things,
and we will talk more about that,
so then they will have the
complete perimeter protection.
And the rest of the session will focus on
how to protect all this traffic direction,
all these different
ingress and egress points.
So now I will hand it over to Megha,
who will talk more about CloudFront
and security at the edge.
- Thank you, Shovan.
Hi, all. Just checking if
you can hear me all right.
Thank you.
How many of you are
familiar with CloudFront?
Well, that's a fair bit.
And as you know,
CloudFront is the content
delivery network for AWS.
It is a reverse proxy.
And when you think about CDN,
content delivery network,
you often think about performance.
You think about acceleration,
caching at the edge.
But CloudFront also
plays an important role
in protecting your applications
from large-scale attacks,
DDoS attacks, and such.
And that is what I want to
talk about in this session.
My name is Megha Kande.
I lead the CloudFront
product management team.
And let's jump into this.
So let's think about the customer
that Shovan talked about, SecureShop.
They have an application.
The application has some
public-facing resources.
and those resources take
in a bunch of traffic
from the Internet.
Now let's look at the
anatomy of this traffic
that may be coming to the
SecureShop applications.
Over half of this traffic is bots today.
And we know that this bot
volume is growing every day
with more agentic bots coming forth.
This is top of mind for SecureShop
because not all bot traffic
drives business growth,
but all bot traffic drives
infrastructure cost.
So this is something that
SecureShop wants to monitor,
control pretty closely.
Second thing that's top
of mind for SecureShop
is the growing volume of DDoS attacks.
So we know that every year,
the volume of DDoS grows
pretty significantly.
In the last two years, DDoS
attack volumes have grown 400%.
What does this mean for an application?
Like when you think about
a 20-plus TBPS attack
that is hitting a
particular cloud provider,
you have to be concerned
about the availability
and resiliency of your own application.
So that's top of mind.
And then finally, SecureShop
is an e-commerce application.
There are some common threats
they have to worry about all the time,
like is somebody creating
a fraudulent account?
Is a legitimate customer
account being taken over?
Is there some malicious
script, cross-site script
that is coming to their application
that may expose customer data
and make them lose customer trust?
All of these things are
top of mind for SecureShop
and they want an application security tool
that has the scale to prevent the attacks,
has the coverage to prevent
different types of attacks
and it's easy to use.
Not every application
builder is a security expert
and there's no need for them to be so.
So how do we solve for this?
This is where the AWS
Edge and CloudFront help.
It starts with scale.
CloudFront is deployed at
the edge of the AWS network.
We have 750 different points of presence.
These are racks of
servers that are deployed
across 750 different
locations in 100 plus cities,
in 50 plus countries.
So this is a pretty widespread surface
that can absorb incoming
requests and diffuse it.
So essentially when there
is a large volume of traffic
that comes into CloudFront,
one of the basic things
that CloudFront does
is spreads the traffic
across its edge pubs.
Now, on each of those PoPs,
on the same server as CloudFront,
you have the AWS web
application firewall running.
So, web application firewall can then take
that diffused traffic and figure out
whether this is legitimate traffic
that should access the application
or it should be blocked.
And along with this, at the edge,
you also have the Layer 3/Layer 4 shield
that prevents Layer
3/Layer 4 DDoS attacks.
So this is the scale.
And when you think about
the edge services for AWS,
you have CloudFront, you have AWS WAF,
you have Shield that are running
on this scaled-out infrastructure
that is sitting in front
of your applications.
This application could be an
ALB endpoint in the region.
It can be an on-prem
application that is running
in your own data centers,
though the edge services
provide that layer of protection
to your services.
But functionally, what goes on here,
let's take a deeper look at that.
The edge services take
in all the traffic coming
from Internet to your applications.
This could be legitimate customer traffic.
This could be malicious attack traffic.
And the first thing that
happens is a network connection
is established, which is
monitored by the AWS Shield.
So when this network connection
is being established,
the first thing that
Shield does is it examines
the IP addresses that a
certain request is coming from.
And AWS constantly maintains
a list of malicious IP addresses,
looking at all the
traffic that comes to AWS.
It's a list of known
offenders, which have,
according to our databases,
our data, launched an attack.
In addition to this, there are
also honeypots that AWS has.
Shovan will talk about
that a little bit later
in this session.
And this known offender's IP list,
if a request is seen coming
from this set of IPs,
it is blocked at the edge by the shield.
So that's first layer.
But then also, at this
stage, at the network layer,
you're setting up a TCP connection,
which are subject to SYN flood attacks.
Shield protects against that.
And it also examines every packet
that is going through the
network layer to make sure
that it is not corrupt,
it is configured correctly
using technologies
such as checksums, simple things.
But they all come together to make sure
that your network layer
connection is protected.
Once the network
connection is established,
CloudFront then starts to
terminate the TLS connection
at the edge and it sets
up a HTTP connection.
Now, for setting up TLS, CloudFront,
working with our security team within AWS,
provides a set of advanced ciphers
that you can configure
for your TLS handshakes.
Recently, we also launched support
for post-content compute-enabled keys.
And this makes sure that
the keys that you use
in your TLS handshake
cannot be harvested now
and then reused later
for account takeover.
So TLS Handshake is one thing.
And then like another capability
that we launched recently
is Mutual TLS with client applications.
Mutual TLS is a technology
that has been around for some time.
With CloudFront,
now you can have a completely
managed version of it
where you can control
and create a trust store on CloudFront,
issue certificates to your clients,
and then make sure that the
TLS handshake establishes
a two-way auth between CloudFront
and your client applications.
So if SecureShop, for example,
has a point of sale somewhere,
that machine can authenticate
itself to CloudFront
before all the data is
then sent over the machine
and a transaction is then enabled.
So this is like setting
up of an HTTP session.
Once this is done, now
your application is open
to talk to a client.
And once that happens,
there is, of course,
a new attack surface
where incoming requests
could be malicious.
And this is where AWS WAF steps in,
which gives you a set of
configurable rules to make sure
that the requests that are
coming to your application
are legitimate, are the requests
that you want your application to take.
So this could include
things like your rate limit,
how many requests can
come to your application.
You can look at bot prevention.
You can look at DDoS
management at Layer 7.
So this is about how you
establish connections,
how you examine requests
coming into the AWS Edge,
but then there is also a
connection that is established
between CloudFront and your application
that is running in AWS Data Center.
And we pay a lot of
attention to that connection.
And because ultimately, like
if your application endpoint
in the region is exposed to the Internet,
that could be another
attack surface as well.
Of course, you can
configure WAF and Shield
on the application in the region.
But CloudFront also allows
you to limit the requests
that are hitting the application,
that are served by the application,
such that those requests
are coming from CloudFront.
So that authentication mechanism exists.
One of the auth mechanisms
that we built way back
when we launched CloudFront,
now like 17 years back,
was an auth token that
CloudFront sends a signature
to S3 buckets.
But recently, in the last year,
we've also developed a
way to connect to an ALB,
a network load balancer,
or EC2 instances that are in private VPCs.
So if you have a way to
shield your application
from internet and expose
it only to connections
from CloudFront, you are
removing another attack surface
from your applications.
So this is all the
different like, you know,
layers of security that
services at the edge provide
for your application protection.
But this is a lot.
So one of the things
that's top of mind for us
is also to make sure
that it's easy to use.
These configurations are easy to apply.
And here, the first thing
that AWS offers with AWS WAF
is a set of managed rules.
These managed rules
are constantly curated,
so you don't have to worry about
different types of attacks,
but you get a package
rule that you can apply
to your application pretty quickly.
First type of rule,
I'll walk through a
few examples over here.
There are many more,
but to SecureShop, that is
an E-commerce application,
there are a few that are pertinent.
The first one is a set
of just baseline rules.
So an example here would be
like there are top 10 security risks
that are identified by the OWASP standard.
And we have a managed rule that constantly
has protection against all of those risks.
Another example of a basic
rule would be that like,
hey, is my incoming request well-formed?
Is my URI correct?
All of those things can be applied through
a simple basic rule.
Second is a set of
managed bot control rules
that CloudFront offers.
Here, you can configure a common bot rule
which just checks that an incoming request
is actually from either a legit user
or from a set of verified bots.
Or you can have a very
targeted bot rule set
to your application.
For example, in this case,
for an E-commerce application,
there can be cart-stuffing bots,
which can be prevented from
accessing your application
using targeted bot rule set.
Other rule sets that are available
are DDoS protection rules.
I'll talk about this
in a little more detail
because we made some changes
that are interesting over here.
And also rules that prevent account fraud,
account takeover, and such.
So with these set of managed
rules, AWS WAF makes sure
that you have basic
security configurations
that are available and easily applied.
So I talked about the DDoS managed rule.
Let's look into this
because this has evolved
as DDoS attacks have evolved
over the last few years.
We've been working on this,
and we recently launched
a Layer 7 DDoS protection
managed rule in AWS WAF.
This rule is faster.
It acts within a few seconds
versus it used to take a
few minutes in the past.
It's more accurate.
It has less false positives as compared
to the previous rule set
because it integrates a lot
of signals from AWS MadBot.
Again, like Shovan will talk
a little more about that.
And also, it allows you
more granular control on
when the rule is applied.
So when we say granular control,
what does that mean, right?
So firstly, it lets you
set configurations like,
do you want to examine every request?
Or do you want to only challenge requests
that have suspicious DDoS indicators
as predicted by the rule?
So it's efficiency versus coverage.
It also allows you to
configure certain parameters
like if you want to exclude
certain IP addresses
because they are trusted.
If you want to include certain
more vulnerable URI patterns,
those things can be configured
and then you can configure your action.
So you can say that like hey,
if this is a DDoS request
I want to actually challenge
this versus block this.
So you can have those settings
and you can pick and choose.
Anything that is blocked or examined
is logged using CloudWatch.
And this new DDoS Layer
7 rule is available
with Shield Advanced.
Shield Advanced is a bundled product.
It's a subscription-based
product that we have.
And with Shield Advanced,
you have 50 billion requests
that can be examined using
the Layer 7 DDoS protection.
So this is one of the things
that we introduced this year.
The other factor is
security for your origins
that are running in private VPCs.
I talked about this briefly,
but I wanted to double-click into this.
So imagine that there is an application.
So in case of SecureShop,
they have their homepage
along with the login,
the sign-in page that they
are running on EC2 instances
in a region, and it is fronted
by an application load balancer.
Now, they want to make
sure that this homepage
is not exposed on the internet.
It doesn't have a public IP,
but at the same point of time,
they want to make sure that this is fast
and it can reach the global
customers for SecureShop
with as low latency as possible.
So now with the support
for private origins,
VPC origins within CloudFront,
SecureShop can go to
the CloudFront console
and they can quickly configure
a VPC origin connection
using CloudFront.
What happens behind the
scene is CloudFront sets up
a parallel VPC, and it
connects the CloudFront VPC
with the customer's VPC
using a VPC to VPC NAT.
All of this is done behind the scenes,
completely managed by CloudFront
with no additional costs.
And then the CloudFront distribution
is configured on top of this.
So now, your application is
not exposed on the internet.
It can only be accessed by CloudFront
over a private ENI connection.
And you have removed
another layer of attack
from your applications.
So these are a few things to recap,
like using the edge
services, using CloudFront,
using AWS WAF, using Shield.
The AWS Edge Services are able to provide
a suite of tools to
customers that are scalable,
that have the complete coverage
to protect against
different forms of attacks,
and are easy to configure.
I would now hand it over to Sohaib,
who is going to show us a cool demo
on how easily you can set this up.
Thank you.
- Thanks, Megha.
Good evening, everyone.
So Megha talked about
a lot of cool Edge
Services security features.
So in this demo, we are going to deploy
some of those security features
using our AI service called Kiro CLI.
How many people have used QCLI?
Okay, we have a few people.
So Kiro CLI is basically
used to be called QCLI.
And now it's Kiro CLI.
It's an AI agent that can reside
in your command line terminal,
and then you can use it with
natural language prompts
to interact with your AWS resources.
So in this demo, we are
deploying a retail application
for SecureShop from scratch,
but you can use Kiro to deploy
these edge security features
on your existing applications as well.
So let's look into our demo architecture.
So we have a fairly
simple architecture here.
We have a static retail SecureShop website
hosted on Amazon S3.
It's called Amazon S3 Origin.
And then our goal here
is to implement caching
and some of the security protections,
such as, you know, protection
against DDoS attacks,
SQL injection, cross-site
scripting, and so on.
We also want to enforce
only HTTPS connections
to our application.
This is internet-facing, so
we only want internet users
to be able to use encrypted connection.
And then we also want to
enable origin access control
to make sure that the only
authenticated requests
are coming from CloudFront
to the Amazon S3 origin.
And then finally, we also want
to implement some WAF rules.
So what I did, I basically started
with a very simple prompt with Kiro.
So I basically told Kiro to deploy
this retail web application
in my AWS account.
And then Kiro knows the best practices,
security best practices,
AWS best practices.
So you can actually interact with Kiro,
and you can ask, hey, this
is my type of application,
and I want to deploy
security best practices.
So it will deploy all those rules.
So I did that, I gave a prompt.
My initial prompt, you
can scan the QR code.
You can take a look at it.
Kiro came up with a plan,
deployed the application on S3 bucket,
and then config the
CloudFront distribution
along with the WAF rules
to protect my application
against these threats.
And I had to do some
back and forth prompts,
I will say this.
You have to sometimes break larger prompts
into smaller prompts
so that the AI is kind of more narrow
in terms of the API calls it's making,
the resources looking into.
So I did some of that.
And once I did that,
Kiro was able to kind of,
you know, come up with this final output
where I have my application
hosted on CloudFront.
I'm using the CloudFront
DNS provided name here.
You can also use your
own DNS using Graph 53.
This is a demo.
So CloudFront DNS is enough.
You can see that there's an S3 bucket
where my retail static page was hosted.
And then Kiro has enabled
a bunch of web application
firewall rules out of the box,
like for example, SQL
injection managed rule,
cross-site scripting.
And then it also deployed
rate limiting rule
that can also help you absorb
a lot of traffic and DDoS attacks.
It did that.
So, you know,
anytime there is more than
200 requests per five minute,
it will basically block
those additional requests.
And then finally, it's also
deployed geo-blocking rule
to only allow requests
from US in this scenario.
And then it's also
looking for bad requests
in my HTTP headers.
And I'm also shipping
the logs into CloudWatch.
That's, again, one of the best practices.
So Kiro implemented that as well
so that I can look into the log data
for troubleshooting purposes
and also understanding
my traffic patterns to adopt
my or to adapt my WAF rules.
So this is what our final
retail website looks like
for SecureShop with some product catalog.
Users can log into it.
I also kind of, you know, ask
Kiro to add some demo traffic
or give me option to
generate some demo traffic.
So it added these buttons.
So once I did that, I was able to generate
and simulate some attacks on
my publicly available website.
So looking at some of the metrics,
you can see that I was able to generate
around 1,400 requests.
51 of those were blocked.
You can also see some of the top attacks.
These metrics are available
in the CloudFront,
so if you're using CloudFront,
you can just quickly
go and look into these.
And then you can also see, finally,
that I'm only receiving
requests from the U.S.
because I have a
geoblocking filter going on.
And these are the list of managed rules,
and custom rules that Kiro
deployed behind the scene
to achieve these protections.
So I have some managed rules.
Megha talked about some
of these, for example,
the SQL injection rule,
the known bad input rule, and others.
And then I also have custom rules,
which is the rate limit
rule and the geo block rule.
So by using Kiro and some
of the security protection
and features that Megha talked about,
we are able to secure this
SecureShop retail website.
As you can see on this
screen, it's a secure website
only supporting the HTTPS connections.
We have WAF policy,
which has all the different
rules that we talked about.
We configured a protocol policy
that is redirecting all the
HTTP traffic into HTTPS,
a very simple configuration that Kiro did.
And then finally, we have
origin access control
enabled on Amazon S3 origin
to only allow authenticated requests
from CloudFront to our S3 bucket.
So this kind of brings us
towards the end of the demo.
You can deploy all of this
through console as well,
but now you have options
to use AI services.
If you want to learn more
about how you can use
some of our other AI services
for deploying secure applications
or any of our other networking
and content delivery services,
you can scan QR code.
There's a blog on this page or this slide,
and there's also a Twitch
video that you can watch.
And today, we also launched an AI agent
for security in preview.
So if you're a security expert
and you want to use AI for that purpose,
you can also look into that.
With that, I will hand it over to Shovan
for walking us through
network traffic inspection.
- Thanks.
Great demo.
You touched upon two of my favorite things
and simplifying customers' life.
First, use GenAI, Kiro, to
build and test environment,
and then the second one was managed rules.
And I will talk more about managed rules
in the context of network firewall.
So in the previous section,
you saw how we can use CloudFront
and Edge Security product
to protect your internet ingress.
Now the customers have
traffic within the network.
For example, they have
the east-west traffic,
traffic coming from one
VPC going to another VPC.
They have north-south traffic,
traffic going from a VPC to the internet.
So how can we use network
firewall to protect this,
both internet egress
as well as the traffic
between application, east-west traffic?
So that's where network
firewall comes into picture.
And SecureShop is getting popular.
It has more users around the world.
It has more traffic now.
It has more employees.
So there is also east-west traffic.
And from network firewall perspective,
it's a managed service.
So no matter how much your traffic grows,
you don't have to do any
infrastructure management.
Network firewall will
scale behind the scene
and handle all your traffic patterns.
And Network Firewall gives
essentially three things to you.
First, it is based on Suricata.
So you can use Suricata rules.
You can write Suricata rules
to inspect your traffic.
You can write stateful rules.
For example, you can say that, hey,
I just want encrypted traffic,
HTTPS traffic from my egress VPCs.
Then you can use it to
do protocol checking,
all those layer three inspections.
It essentially behaves
like an IDS and IPS.
Then it also provides you logs.
You can use it to monitor
how your traffic pattern is,
how your network firewall is behaving.
You can use it for audit purposes,
troubleshooting purposes,
or for compliance checks.
From SecureShop perspective,
they have traffic between VPCs,
traffic coming from Internet,
going to the Internet,
and from on-prem.
And all this traffic comes
to the VPC through gateways.
A network firewall can
act as a bump in the wire.
It is integrated with all
the AWS gateways natively.
For example, it is integrated
with transit gateway.
You can use it as a bump in a wire.
You can use it for all traffic
going in and out of IGW
or traffic coming from
your on-frame through DX
or through VPNs.
Not only that, you can also
drop a firewall endpoint
in your subnet and traffic
going from the subnet
will go to the network firewall endpoint.
It will get inspected
and then it will go to other subnets
or the internet gateway.
And when it comes to manageability,
network firewalls,
it is integrated with AWS Firewall Manager
and your AWS organization.
We already saw that
there are many different traffic patterns
SecureShop is using,
east-west and north-south.
So they have multiple firewall endpoints.
(coughs) not only that they
have different environments,
staging, prod, development,
QA, so at the end of the day,
these are all different AWS accounts
and if you're a security admin
you're managing multiple endpoints
multiple accounts,
but you want a single pane of glass
where you want to manage
all your rules and policies
for all your network firewalls
and firewall manager provides you that
through AWS organization integration.
And when we come to logging
firewall provides logs in S3,
Kinesis Firehose, and CloudWatch logs.
You can export these logs
and send it to your analytics provider.
They will analyze the traffic pattern
and give you analytics.
For example, you can see
which rule was enacted,
where the traffic was coming,
what traffic is getting blocked,
and you can use all this insight
to write more fine-grained
policies or rules in this case.
Many of the times customers tell me that,
hey, Shovan, if I know a thread vector,
I can write a Suricata rule.
But what about I don't
know a thread vector?
It's an emerging thread vector.
So what can I do?
So that's when the managed
rule comes into picture.
We have a group of
honeypots we call madpots.
They continuously detect the Internet.
They analyze all the threats.
And they create a managed rule for you.
They constantly update the managed rules.
And you can use those managed rules
on your network firewall.
we use this MadPot or our Honeypot network
to protect Amazon.com
and we provide the same
infrastructure to our customers
and through that, you can write
or you can use those active threat defense
to protect your application
so that way you are protected against
all the emerging threats.
What's unique about our
Honeypot network is its scale
so we have a global footprint
and just like CloudFront and WAF
it's deployed across our global footprint
So we have tens and thousands of sensors.
These sensors, they mimic
your TCP application,
telnet, SSH, and your HTTP application.
They behave like your human clients,
and they try to act like a decoy.
And the network understands
the signature patterns,
then updates the rule,
and through that you get the protection.
And at our scale, in a given day,
we analyze more than 100
million signature patterns
and keep on constantly
updating these firewall rules.
So you get the same scale
and benefit out of it.
So in the beginning,
we talked that there are four
directions you should protect.
So we covered the three directions.
Now the fourth direction is human access
or your employee access
to this application.
And here we will cover that.
And when we talk about human access,
so there are two different use cases.
The first is most of our employees,
they interact with the
application through a browser.
So these are your
contractors, your HR people,
and they don't do SSH.
So for them, a browser is fine.
But you have your engineers
who actually want to go
and telnet SSH into your instances
and do maintenance and patching.
So they're two different,
and we'll talk about both the use cases.
Before you do that, what happens is that
most of our customers
access AWS network resources
in three different patterns.
First is their VPN into
your on-prem network.
Through the on-prem network,
they will connect through
DX or side-to-side VPN
to AWS resources.
So in this case, the access management
is provided by your on-prem provider,
and then we provide the
pipe back to the AWS.
But you can use, like we
talked in the previous section,
you can use network firewall
to inspect the traffic
coming into AWS through DX or VPNs.
Many times customers say that,
hey, why should I even go to my on-prem?
Why should I manage infrastructure?
Can I directly VPN into my AWS network?
So for that, we provide client VPN.
Then there are a certain set of customers
who are saying that, hey,
most of my employees are using browsers.
So can I provide them an ease
of use, standard browser,
internet-based access, just
like any public applications?
And on top of it, from
a security perspective,
I want a better security posture.
I want more granular controls.
I want to use identity device posture
to provide per application-based access.
So for that, we have
built AWS verified access.
Essentially, they're
asking for zero trust,
and we are providing them
the zero trust access.
So let's first jump into Client VPN.
In Client VPN, the user
will need a client.
So we provide a client.
They deploy it on their laptops.
And then from that laptops,
they connect to the Client VPN endpoint,
which is running in AWS region.
And once the user is authenticated,
then they can access all the resources
in your network in the AWS.
Let's talk about how we
authenticate the user in client VPN.
So, we have three authentication patterns,
and based on your flexibility, your needs,
you can choose one of them.
First is a certificate-based
authentication.
You can put a certificate
on your user's device,
and using the certificate,
they authenticate it to client VPN,
and then they access your network.
The second is active directive.
Many of our customers
use Active Directory,
so we support Active
Directory-based integration.
Let's say you are using
an identity provider
like Okta or Ping who supports SAML
so you can use SAML based
authentication as well,
and based on this authentication
the user gets access to the network.
And you can write granular policy
you can restrict the user access
to a subset of your network
or to a segment of your network.
So in this case, I am restricting
the user to a slash 32
and the user is belonging to
the engineering department.
And many times customers say that, hey,
can I use device posture?
So we provide a Lambda connection handler,
and you can write custom rules
in the connection handler,
and we will run both the
identity-based authentication
and device posture check
through this connection handler,
and if both allow, then the
user get access to the network.
In this case, SecureShop
is using OS versions.
They're using the client version.
They're checking the device
posture, and based on that,
the user is getting access to the network.
And many times, customers ask,
"Hey Shovan, can I use client VPN
to provide access to
my on-prem resources?"
So I don't want to
maintain two VPN solutions,
or I can provide them
access to other clouds.
So what happens is that your
users will get authenticated
at the client VPN endpoint,
and then through DXO site-to-site,
that request will go back to your on-prem.
So based on that, you can
have on-prem-based access.
And we just launched DX
multi-cloud connector,
so with that, you can also
provide access to other clouds.
So in a nutshell,
the client VPN can give
you access not only to AWS,
but other resources outside of AWS.
Now let's talk about Zero
Trust Verified Access, or AVA.
We call it AVA.
And AVA is built on AWS
Zero Trust principles.
So let's talk about that.
Because Zero Trust can
mean different things
to different folks.
So it's important to understand
what is our perspective
and how we define Zero Trust.
From our perspective, zero
trust is essentially two things.
First, we say that apart
from network location,
you should use non-network-based signals
to provide access to a
resource or to a network.
So in case of SecureShop,
they can use identity-based
as a non-networking signal.
They can also use device posture.
The more signals you use,
the better the trust
authentication mechanism
becomes better your
security posture becomes.
The second thing is
continuous verification.
So let's take an example.
If user wants to access application one,
zero trust principle says
that check device posture,
check identity, run your policy,
and then give access to application one.
Moments later,
if the same user wants to
access application two,
then pull in the same trust signals,
identity and posture,
because something might have
changed in that brief moment.
Application two might have
a different set of policies,
so run this policy
and then give the user
access to application two.
So these are the two pillars
of our zero trust principles.
And we built AWS verified access
based on these two principles.
(coughs) So from AWS verified
access is a reverse proxy.
All the HTTP requests come
to AWS verified access.
It terminates the request.
Then it pulls down the claims
from your identity provider,
your device management provider,
and we have standard-based integration.
Essentially, what we want is that
you shouldn't change your
identity provider or device MDMs
for the sake of moving to
zero trust architecture.
So you can still continue
with your IT investment
and use AWS verified access
to provide zero trust access.
Then we pull the signals,
run the policies.
If the policy allow,
we connect the user's
request back to your VPC.
And a customer might
have hundreds of VPCs,
thousands of applications.
From an administrative perspective,
you just need one single
AWS verified access,
and we will connect it on the backend
to your application or to
your VPC or to your ALB,
wherever the application is running.
So we do the backend stitching.
We provide the
point-to-point connectivity.
Unlike some of the other solutions
which requires you to use
connectors or publishers,
so here you don't have
to do all those things.
From a security perspective,
you just write policies
and grant access, and we
take care of the plumbing.
So we talked about the partners.
These are the partners from
identity space, MDM space,
and they are partners
who consume our logs,
give you analytics.
If your identity provider
or MDM is not there,
their logo is not there, let us know.
We will work with them and get them here.
So we have a standard-based integration,
and we can work with them
to get them onboarded.
So let's talk about a few capabilities.
One is that first, AVA
provides an internet endpoint
to your private application.
So in that sense,
it is exposed to the
internet-based threats.
So the first thing you need to build
is a security perimeter.
So we provide WAF integrations,
and all the things Megha
and Sohaib talked about,
for example, DDoS, SQL injections,
cross-site scripting bots,
all those things are provided on AVA.
You first filter the traffic,
provide the broad network perimeter,
then use AVA's identity
and device management
based zero trust access
and then provide user
into your applications.
And then the final,
the second thing I want to touch is
AVA also provides you rich logs.
you can, in the enhanced logging mode,
you can dump all your claims.
And later on, you can use
those claims to write policies.
You can write policies, tweak policies,
simulate the policies,
see what's the effect of those policies,
and then check those in.
Many of my customers have said that
using this advanced logging
and the policy editor,
they have cut down the policy writing time
from days to a few hours.
So it's quite powerful and quite useful,
and Sohaib will talk more about that.
So having said that, now I
will give it back to Sohaib.
Before moving that, one other thing,
one common question is that
when should I use client VPN
and when should I use verified access?
And the answer is that
based on a use case,
you will use both.
To provide network access, use client VPN.
It gives the SSH and Telnet another access
to your engineers.
And for your employees who
need HTTP-based access,
use AWS Verified Access.
It will give you the granular access
based on device poster and identity.
All right, Sohaib, take on
and give us the next set of demos.
- Thanks, Shovan.
So Shovan talked about
a lot of cool features
of Amazon Verified Access,
and let's apply some of them
to a real-world use case.
So going back to our SecureShop customers,
so they also have an internal application,
financial application,
we are calling it FinanceCore application.
So in this demo, we are going to apply
some of the AVA security features
to this FinanceCore application
to provide secure remote
access for internal users.
So in our demo
architecture, we have a user
that browses a domain hosted on Route 53.
This is called financecore.secureshop.com.
You can see name this to our
verified access endpoint.
And then on verified access endpoint,
we have configured a bunch of things.
So we have WAF rules through
AWS Managed WAF rules,
which can provide protection
against the bot control,
the common threat such as
SQL injection and so on.
The verified access also
requires a user to authenticate
against IAM Identity Center.
This is our trust provider.
You can also use a device trust provider
in addition to this,
like Shovan talked about.
But for demo purposes,
we are only using the IAM Identity Center
as a trust provider.
And then once the user is
authenticated successfully,
they're able to navigate or browse
to this FinanceCore application
running behind a private ALB.
We also have the FinanceCore application
also have to go out to internet,
download security patches,
maybe talk to third-party APIs.
So it also needs that
outbound internet egress.
So we also want to protect that parameter.
So we are also deploying
AWS Network Firewall
to protect that egress traffic as well.
And then finally, we are shipping the logs
from WAF, from verified access,
and from network firewall
into CloudWatch, so that we can use them
for troubleshooting, for
analyzing our access patterns,
and for also auditability purposes.
So, with this, I will actually
switch to a live demo.
Give me a second, let
me log into my machine.
Hopefully, the demo gods are kind today.
Okay, so again, I use Kiro to deploy
all of this architecture
that I showed you.
So let's first navigate into
our FinanceCore application.
So when I try to navigate
to FinanceCore application,
it basically redirects
me to log into my account
using IAM Identity Center,
like I showed in the architecture.
So I'll do that here.
Give it my password.
Okay, I'm able to remember
my password finally.
So, now I'm actually browsing to this ALB
that is behind the verified access.
Now, this is my FinanceCore dashboard.
You can see this is like
a financial application
for internal employees who are looking for
like revenue numbers and things like that.
You can see, you know, I'm
running this in US East one.
This is my EC2 instance for
the FinanceCore application.
And this is all behind the verified access
like I showed you previously.
So let's look into what is
going on behind the scene.
So I want to look into
the verified access.
So verified access is in the VPC console.
So I will navigate towards our VPC console
and then go to verified
access, which is this.
So this is my re:Invent demo.
Let me make it a little bigger.
So if I select this,
you can see this is like
the general information
about my verified access instance.
And then I have a finance app group
so that I can apply the group policy
to only allow access for
my users from that group.
This is my trust provider.
Like I said, I am using
the IAM Identity Center
as a trust provider.
you can also attach, for example,
a device, a trust provider like this.
I'm not going to do that in this demo.
I have also the logging going on
like I talked about to CloudWatch
and I'm also passing the detail logs.
So I'm also passing the trust
context into the CloudWatch
that I can use as part
of the policy tests.
And then finally, I have a
WAF policy or WebACL assigned
to the verified access.
I'll come back to it later
to look into the rules.
Well, let's first look into the,
there's a feature within verified access,
it's called launch policy assistant.
So, in order to, you know,
fine tune your policies
and make sure that your
policies are working
the way they should, you
can use this feature.
So, I can actually use my
email address in this scenario.
I select my endpoint.
In actual production environment,
you may have different endpoints.
you may have an endpoint for
prod, non-prod, and so on.
I only have one because I
have a demo environment.
And then I'm going to use
my last authorization result
to apply this policy or change the policy.
It takes a little bit while.
Okay.
So you can see that AVA
was able to actually extract trust context
from my trust provider.
In this case, IAM identity center.
This is all the information
that was passed by
the IAM identity center to AVA.
You can see it has my email address,
my host name, my IP address.
The one that I'm interested in
is the group, which is this.
So right now, I have a
pretty open group policy,
which is allowing access
to any authenticated user.
I want to narrow it down
to this finance group.
So I only want the people who
are part of the finance group
to be able to access this application.
So what I do, I can change the policy.
I actually pre-created the policy.
Again, I use Kiro for
generating this policy as well.
So you can see I am
just using the group ID,
which is this, which matches this,
to narrow down this policy.
And I want to test this policy
to make sure that it works.
It seems like it works.
So I hit next,
and then I can simply apply this policy
to my Amazon verified access instance.
Okay, so that was the
launch policy assistant,
so you can use it for troubleshooting
and for fine-tuning your policy.
The other thing I'm going
to talk about is WAF.
So I have also deployed the
WAF, again, through Kiro.
So I'm going to actually
jump on Kiro, which is this.
So I preloaded the context
for my FinanceCore application into Kiro
in order for us to interact
with this architecture.
So I'll say, show me WAF
rules on FinanceCore.
And I will say this.
You have to name your
resources really, really well
because this is a large language model.
So the better your naming convention is,
it is going to perform better
in response to your prompts.
Something to keep in mind.
So you can see that I ran
this prompt right away.
It's returned some rules to me.
And I can ask it.
Before I do that, let me
show you in the console.
So I have the same rules over here.
But you can see that when Kiro responded
to the same request, it
ran some describe calls.
And it showed me the rules,
but it's also telling me
what the rule is doing.
Very brief summary.
So it has that knowledge.
And if you're not ready to use Kiro
for deploying production applications
or making changes to your resources,
you can still use it for
network discovery like this.
Very safe use case.
So I would like, what other WAF rules
I should deploy for this
financial application?
Like I said, it has the knowledge,
so it knows the security best practices,
it knows AWS has security
best practices as well,
are well-architected frameworks,
so it is suggesting me some options.
So I'm going to say,
so you can see it gave me
a lot of different rules.
I'm not going to go through all of them,
but I'm going to pick the first one,
and I'm going to say add
this first managed rule.
So this is more like I'm making changes
to the resources key,
so it takes a little bit more time.
So while this is going on,
I'm going to jump on my console again,
and you can see it was able to do it.
If I refresh my page,
I should be able to see that rule.
You can see that this was a rule I added,
SQL injection rule set,
which is exactly like this.
So you can see, like, with a few prompts,
I'm able to make changes to my resources
and apply some additional
security protections
for this internal financial application.
Okay, so the other thing I
had was network firewall.
So I also want to use...
I also want to show you
how the network firewall
is working in this scenario.
So I want to see the route table
because I'm passing all of my traffic
to the network firewall endpoint.
So show me the FinanceCore
VPC route table,
ignore unused route.
Show me in Cisco format.
Just for fun.
So again, this is again a discovery call.
So I'm learning about the routes in my VPC
for this FinanceCore application.
So it's running a bunch
of the describe calls
behind the scene.
And you can see that it started to kind of
spit out the route table I have in place.
So you can see that I have
a route table associated
to my finance for application.
These subnets, so it's
sending all the traffic
to the VPC endpoint, which is
the network firewall endpoint,
which is this right here.
And then I have firewall subnets
where my network firewall
is actually deployed.
So that subnet has a route
to the internet gateway, rightly so.
And then I also have
a route table assigned
to internet gateway for the return traffic
to go through the
network firewall as well.
So you can see that I
also have routing set up
for that as well.
And if I say, show me the
traffic flow in both sides,
so Kiro will be able to find
that as well for me in a bit.
So you can see that, you
know, it's showing me
how the traffic from Internet user
will basically interact with
this FinanceCore application.
I'm not going to go through everything,
but you can see it's
identifying everything,
like the WAF rules, the
network firewall rules,
the routing, everything,
and it's showing me both
inbound and outbound.
Again, a very quick way
to verify your setup.
So now I want to go to network firewall
to show you some of the rules
in place in the console.
Network firewall is also
part of the VPC console,
so I'll quickly jump into that.
So this is my network
firewall FinanceCore,
and I have a bunch of different
things configured here.
The one that we are going to look into
is the policy, which is this.
And I have configured
a bunch of custom rule
and AWS managed rule
that Shovan talked about.
So the AWS managed rule I've enabled here
are protecting me against
known malware domains.
And then the custom
rule that I've created,
again, using Kiro,
is making sure that I can only send
encrypted traffic out to the internet.
So I'm blocking any traffic
going on port 80, HTTP traffic.
I'm also blocking any
traffic going out on port 22.
Because this is a financial application,
it should not be making any SSH connection
out to the internet.
So it's blocking all of these
kind of traffic patterns.
And let's test these things.
So I'm going to go to my EC2 console.
I have my FinanceCore application
running in the subnet.
So if I connect to it
using the private IP,
and I have copied some
commands so I can run them.
So the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to curl Amazon.com and HTTP.
This should be blocked.
And as you can see,
this was blocked by the network firewall.
And then if I try to curl
HTTPS, it should work.
You can see this worked.
And then finally, if I try to connect
to a known malware domain,
it should also be blocked based
on my network firewall rule.
So you can see that also happened here.
So with that, that kind of brings us
towards the end of the demo.
You can also use, it might
take a little bit more time.
Let me see how much time I have.
Okay, so you can also run other queries
to, for example, show you the
blocked traffic in the logs.
So Kiro can actually go and
make those describe calls
against my CloudWatch log group
and show me those entries as well
in a summarize, easily consumable fashion.
It takes a little bit.
You can see now it started
showing me some of those data,
what IP addresses were allowed,
what attempts were blocked.
There's a lot of data I'm
not going to go through,
but just to show you that
it can consume the log data
and give you summarized output.
So with that, this was the console demo.
So coming back to our slide deck,
so we covered a lot of
ground in this session.
We talked about different AWS services
that you can use for building
robust parameter protection
and zero trust.
So let's apply all of those things
that we learned along this session
to our SecureShop enterprise architecture.
So the first thing SecureShop want to do,
we want to protect our
internal applications.
So we deploy Amazon verified
access with identity
and device trust provider integrations.
Then we enable web application firewall
on both CloudFront and verified access
to protect both our
public facing applications
like the retail application we showed
and our internal applications
like the financial application
against the common threats.
We then deploy network
firewall to inspect north-south
and east-west traffic.
So north-south traffic
is the traffic coming
from internet towards our application,
and also from on-premises over
the DX to our application.
And also east-west traffic
that is flowing between,
let's say, prod to non-prod,
one application to a
different application residing
across different VPCs.
So you're using network firewall
to protect against all of those
or inspect all of that traffic pattern.
And then lastly, we filter
and we inspect internet-bound
traffic, outbound traffic
using AWS Network Firewall.
And optionally, we can also
enable Route 53 DNS Firewall
for that DNS protection
for egress traffic protection as well.
So all of this help us create
a secure network parameter
for Secure Shop Enterprise customer.
So this brings us towards
the end of our session.
thanks for joining us
please take a moment to
take the session survey
in the mobile app
and that can help us
improve our future sessions.
Enjoy the rest of the
re:Invent and keep reinventing
and if you have any questions
we are going to be in the back
so please come chat with us, thank you.